jibril ont pas si mon doc c'est très
simple je vous dis tout de suite voilà
il ya un bail là c'est le penalty de
l'impossible elle va reculer à chaque
fois on va jouer tous et ceux qui
veulent jouer géraldine aussi le jour
non merci
geraldine page ou également non mais
vous n'êtes pas en tenue voulait jouer
quand même on n'était pas toujours
bonjour est quand même alors c'est très
simple les mecs on va reculer de plus en
plus il va falloir mettre là le ballon
entre les deux poteaux d'accord et oui à
quoi ton les dépôts pourront donc
inquiète regardez moi je suis je suis je
me dis chaussures savoir tourner avec
djibril s'échoue t'inquiète inquiétait
contraire
plus ça va plus loin que le show propose
qu'on démarre aussi ce parce que c'est
facile non d'accord aussi sur veut pas
si facile débat un mois
cinéma attention visible on a tous
chance à chaque fois de chance à chaque
fois c'est fait c'est bon merci
peut-être j'aimerais le débris lattois
frérot vas-y on démarre aussi son débat
non allez c'est parti et francesca prêt
ce sera francesca géraldine et docks qui
est toujours étonnant dans les jouets un
cran badie frère très vas-y vas-y
oh quel point tu vas me manquer non ok
d'accord voilà comme ça tu vois des
damnés vas-y vas-y oui j'ai aussi pas
dit aussi après ça c'est à toi soit
d'autre ok après
alors attention va être regardé voilà
parce que voilà voilà montreux du cerro
le pied cassé le pied c'est le viet
président a alors demandé d'en trouver
les frères est pourquoi tu vois entendez
l'enfer ou carrément à l'alm toi tu
perds ou tu perds tous hétéros à tokyo
au parent direct léopard audition par
audi sal aux abords des bassidjis gros
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
danger c'est dit c'est pas la tenue que
t'as pas la tenue pour être pédalait
nahla style c'est le principal c'est
vrai talent c'est vrai
ce fut presque quarante ans de carrière
taillé hausse et djibril cissé raconte
avec till havoc week-end avec owens un
câble cpe
tu peux aller chercher ton ballon les
prises de tête
j'avais choisi la deuxième et si je suis
ok au look what you hate un deuxième
essai attention vas-y un peu plus à
droite
alors moi j'ai décidé je fais la passe
sur le dise je passe directe aux abonnés
à jeter n'a pas ouvrir la porte
bah non c'est vrai la première parce que
ça par contre si ça devenait vraiment me
donner cette odeur non c'est riche mais
voilà celui qui le met dehors et yann
quoi franchement celui qu'il omet de
dehors à cette hybride moitié fils
adorent c'est choquant mais dc dc dc dc
vas-y vas-y oui l'attenté sera le tube
francs dernier thibault parce que c'est
toi c'est toi c'est me qu'on finisse par
quoi va-t-il pas du tout mais natif de
thiès qu'avaient-ils rappel du shérif
elle choisit quel beau nom du groupe des
77 ans ensemble
elle va y arriver tous mais je l'espère
merci vas-y à toi pas si tu veux ou tu
veux pas d'accord il est pas mal
aux cayes à gaga la tuberie vas-y
pourquoi s'est il emporté par le 2 août
à 18 2 2 il est très tentant
vas-y va le mettre mal mais je le
connais je le connais il m je le connais
il va le mettre fin aux tensions à me
convaincre attention la mi temps a
permis d'arrêter voilà temps obama doit
faire un fou oui pourquoi pas je voulais
faire et je me suis joint draquila tant
que personne de la mieux connue madrelle
martin michaud allez je vous somme de
bâle et yb l'année
il dit